what does a sphere look like the best
example would be a football it's round
in shape and has no vertices but how do
we show it on paper it will look
something like this this is the center
of the sphere let's call it o another
important thing we need to know about
the sphere is that all points on the
surface are equidistant from its Center
let us name these points a b and c it
means o a o b and OC will all be equal
and that distance is called the radius
of the sphere so if R is the radius of
the sphere O A will be equal to r o b
will be equal to R and even length OC
will be equal to
R is there any other another way in
which we can visualize a
sphere how about we take a semicircle on
a plane a semicircle is half a
circle and this red line is its
diameter when this semicircle is
revolved
360° around the diameter we get a
[Music]
sphere